welcome back Tony avoganim is a cocktail
culture Pioneer he is the master of
Mixology and he's joining us today to
showcase the perfect holiday drinks and
give us a preview of the upcoming tag
Spirit Awards it's good to see you buddy
hey JC always a planet it's always great
having you here in the kitchen you've
brought some stuff today to make a
holiday cocktail what are we making well
the holidays are my favorite time to
entertain and holiday cocktails just go
hand in hand and what I've got is a
tradition I started in San Francisco
before I came out to the Bellagio in Las
Vegas and I've been doing it ever since
it's my hot buttered rum and I'm gonna
put you to work making all right man
what am I doing all right so we got a
half a pound of softened butter in there
we're gonna add one pound of light brown
sugar you can just dump that all those
ingredients here yeah those are our
spices dump them in yeah go ahead we've
got ground allspice you've got nutmeg
all right you got some vanilla extract
don't put it in here and it wouldn't be
the holidays without ground cinnamon all
right then you're gonna Mash all this
stuff up we're all gonna mash it up mash
it all up this is the thing about
holiday entertaining JC is that you want
to do as much in advance as you can you
want to prepare a punch or an eggnog the
night before let those flavors come
together and the same thing with my hot
buttered rum batter which I made last
night at home ah there it is that's what
you want to do because you want to
entertain your guests making that making
everything in the kitchen absolutely
right so this I made last night it's
just like making a good gravy all those
spices everything comes together it kind
of just tastes better the next day or
two so we're going to do is we're going
to take a couple of heaping teaspoons of
the batter putting it right into and you
gotta have a festive mug I love your
mugs and you're telling me too you warm
up the mugs in advance why are you more
warming up the mugs ahead of time well
hot drink hot cups okay so the Cup
itself will absorb the heat of the drink
if we don't actually add that into a
warm mug now before we add the rum yes I
want you talked about the tag Global
Spirits yes yes this is the glass that
we designed for the tag Global Spirits
Awards which will be held here in Las
Vegas at the Delano January 30th through
February 3rd this is the tasting glass
that we evaluate all the spirits on so
so this is the same spirit in a
different glass why do you have a
different glass why this shaped glass to
really capture all the subtle nuances of
the spirit itself okay to Rum be it a
tequila beer vodka so what I want you to
do is just give it a nose in this glass
oh yeah
oh and a sip okay here we go
that is good that's delicious yeah okay
all right now we're gonna go ahead and
take a little nose on this yeah okay to
go sign up right here
this will get you through Thanksgiving
I'll tell you that much but notice the
difference
all you get really you get that blast of
alcohol from the Apple yeah you're
getting the Great Taste in this in this
glass right in the smell too yeah isn't
it crazy all right okay about a minute
left here now let's go ahead and add two
ounces we're using Appleton estate
Jamaican rum I love for my hot buttered
rums and aged rum um Appleton's just a
beautiful piece you're still preparing
this someone wants to have wine for
Thanksgiving to go with their turkey
what kind of wine do you suggest well
I'll definitely be having wine as well
but I like sancer from France uh it's
the fume Blanc grape it's a little dry
if you're serving oysters as an
appetizer and the stuff you come in here
for Thanksgiving I'm coming to your
house oh my gosh Tony all right so now
we just give that you give that one a
stir Stir It Up here I'll give this one
a stir and also you have we teleporting
real quick where's your event coming up
if you want to learn how to make holiday
cocktails where's your events we're
doing an event at libertine social where
I'm a partner this is December 14th 6 30
to 8 30. we'll be doing uh our hot
buttered rum along with other holiday
cocktails so please tickets available at
secret sugar and hit tag Global Spirits
Awards take spiritsawards.com events for
tickets to all of our consumers that's a
long website let's let's cheers my man
this is delicious I love the mugs I love
your drinks Happy Thanksgiving and Merry
Christmas my friend to you as well thank
you happiness
oh my gosh that is amazing
that is so sweet Jillian we're gonna
drink some cocktails
this is so good